as Robert if you only get one
opportunity to go right because you know
the flying Squad have had to shoot to
kill policy for a number of years so our
biggest fear of going in on any job is
not the fact that we're doing it it's
the fact that when we come out they're
going to shoot us in a chest
[Music]
I grew up in Camden Town minor childhood
was uh
was one of it's quite eventful you know
I I didn't like living in in poverty and
we come from a quite published area
and if you want anything you had to go
and get it especially being uh I've been
among who's a single parent
I can remember a time where we used to
have the trainers used to come through
and uh me and my Powers we used to jump
on the trains taking black bags of us
and just take all the radios out and we
would get off to three or four miles
down the track
and that was really my my early years
what was your experience of school like
um I got expelled when I was about eight
or nine years old
I had a fight with a kid and stabbed him
with a pencil case and I got kicked out
of school
I then got put into a kid's home
and um about 10 years old you know you
know I can always remember going to
being taken to the home for the first
day
and um I was with my social worker and
uh I'm a mum and she said you've got to
stay until for a for a little while for
a couple of weeks and I said why you
know you have to and then I left
and I I've I didn't know what was going
on I was only Young and uh next thing
this guy just make me trying to fight
bam you know next thing that was all on
me and said you're not going anywhere
you know you're going to be here for a
long time
and that's what that for me is when it
really just all started my my in hatred
towards Authority
Against The Establishment and I didn't
want to be
I I just didn't want to be like like
them and they thought that they could
beat him into submission
and when I couldn't they moved me to
another
another home and another home
they put me in a
in a in a flat I was one of the youngest
kids to to sign on and have a flat they
put me in with a with a couple of older
guys that were sharing the flat I was
living in Hampstead
um Bell size Park primroseal I was
surrounded by wealth and after a couple
of months of being now
I was then introduced to
to Robin post obviously's
building societies and and other things
and did you ever get caught or arrested
yeah and you know when I was younger I
got nicked I got Nick for a few armed
robberies as a kid
um
I've done I've done four years in EU for
finders uh prison in Aylesbury the audio
was a piss pot uh and a jug of water in
your cell no television no radio there's
a sign not even a book I think that was
a I've just got four years and that was
that was uh definitely a
knock and juices for me actually
changing or rehabilitating me in fact it
made me more of a holding criminal I I I
worked outside the country for a number
of years
as a young guy
I worked I worked in Spain
and uh I sort of done my apprenticeship
there
where I was running running puff up from
from my bay up to Valencia
I've done that for a few years and um
you know that that was one of those
things that taught me how to get in
control myself because you know we had
we was going for Roadblocks uh so you
had to you had to keep really cool
um normally there'll be three of us I'd
be driving all the all the gear up now
I'll have a front driver that would
phone me if anything was going wrong and
then I'd have a guy behind me a couple
of clicks back and he would have British
number plates
uh so if it looked like there's going to
be a rolling roll block
he I would just phoned him all my other
guy would phone him and tell him there's
a roadblock he would come up and
normally nine out of ten times the
police would would follow him and we
would just slip through because for us
it wasn't a it wasn't about guns and
violence
for us it was just about using our
intellect
it's like which meant no guns just to uh
or no increases violence
um you know as I grew up
I wanted to take the hour of robbery to
the next level
um
which meant for me uh
organizing a team of like-minded guys
but more importantly I wanted to work
with a team of guys that could work
under extreme conditions
men with uh tenacity to overcome their
darkest fears of flight which is a very
recommended team within the British
criminal underworld
in 2007 I was contacted by an underworld
uh uh guy who fixes jobs here processed
on behalf of a bank in uh syndicate
um who wanted us to take over the
Verizon building in in King's Cross
Canada
Verizon holds a
banking data for JP Morgan and some of
the leading banks in America and England
and we came together to pull off a
what the papers described as the Ocean's
11 Heist
um
where we uh
we Nick five million pounds worth of
opinion chips
and uh
100 million pounds of a data they wanted
us to go in there and and first of all
they wanted us to take a specialist with
us
they wanted us to get him in now so he
could download all the their data from
uh from uh from the drives the data
center had eight levels of security
or eight layers of security
which consisted of
a prima a 24-hour role in Patrols
biometric entry system going into the
building
when you go past the main entry system
you come into a thermostatic pressurized
compartment which is about 13 foot long
by about eight foot wide and once you're
in that compartment the door shuts
behind you it pressurizes and the other
door opens you can't open both of them
at the same time
once through there once you get accepted
through that door you then come into
another turnstile into a foyer with a
bulletproof glass with a uniform guard
behind it
he then buzzes you through to another
turnstile where you go in and then
beyond that is another door
with a CTT camera Operator Operator
Suite with freezer security operators in
now and beside them are Panic buttons
but the most important bit of
information that we received is uh on
the drive room and the and the
motherboards room are
there was a private security company
monitoring them
so we had all that security to kind of
overcome and we also had a private uh
security company money down to overcome
at first off I thought you know I told
my guys they said uh you know what's
held if you know this is impossible we
looked at all the schematics of it and
we went through it that you know we went
through it I'm throwing through it and
you know we realized that we couldn't go
in there with guns
we realized we couldn't Ram the doors
because I've got metal doors and I
opened that and plus plus there was free
police stations women within a mile
facility and there was one way in and
one way out and um
as it backs on Silicon now so looking it
just seemed impossible
but you know I didn't wake up every
morning and ask myself am I motivated
enough to do what I do you know I I
didn't care whether
whether jobs are easy or whether they
were odd I didn't care whether I wanted
to do them I didn't you know it was just
a job to me I spent I spent three weeks
looking at we parked across the road and
all different different places and we
just looked at it for three weeks
looking at who worked out who's going in
harmony security guards when now what
were the times their shifts how many how
many uh patrols that they had passed
there were police when you're a security
guard you've got a clock on
or around a building
no
that takes about an hour of all the
security guards so they all have to do
it if that doesn't coincide with the
right timing then the the alarms go off
and and they've and they'll be all a
center automatically so we knew we only
had one hour that's why we gave
ourselves one hour we hired our
warehouse we had this schematics so what
we did for the
why we was looking at it we we we taped
out all the corridors and where it was
so we kept timing it and after three
weeks um we we sat down and we had
another meeting with the fixer and it
you know it just became apparent that
this was was one job that this was
impossible and I was driving over to
West Hampstead
and um
there was a there's all the cars that
were backed off and everyone was looking
up and there was a garnish on the roof
and uh I wound down my wind in as a cop
where I said what's going on he said
there's a guy on the road a friend to
commit suicide
I've got a little thing in my head that
I think I may be able to do so I went
back and told the guys and um we came up
with a different plan
so our plan was
we couldn't Ram it we couldn't do
anything that was going to draw
attention to ourselves so really we had
to
basically goes as a as the enemy and the
enemy to us is the old bill
so we we had um we we went and got an
older police fan
cars
we've got the whole uniform all the
comms and crafts everything the whole
thing was about authenticity about
looking the part we had IDs and
everything else but to make it really
really stand out we took an Alsatian
with us so as a canine unit
so when we pulled up we would look
looking apart
we hired four technicians
so on the date of robbery I I can always
remember we met at the slaughter we
checked all our gear
we checked uh you know make sure the
handcuffs the radios working make sure
all the bands are working the cars so I
was in the front van with my guy and one
of my guys in the back with a dog behind
that was was one of the two guys in the
police car and behind them was four
technicians and in the specialist guy
that we took to download everything oh
we didn't really know he was part of the
banking Syndicate person he was behind
them as we got down now we radio through
for the for the for the Specialists that
pull over and then also for the
technicians to pull across the road
because our job was to take over the
building and call them in and as we were
just about to pull over a siren went off
behind us
and it's a real world bill and uh so we
we pulled her at all I could hear on the
mic said what's going on what's going on
I said just calm down everything's sweet
we let we're going to let him pull past
and see what he does there was only one
old building now so you know we could
easily took him out
um
but he came past the Cyrus they're on
and then the next thing he pulled
forward but we had overshot the mark
they're going in now so we said to
everyone just stay where you are we're
going to drive around the block so we
had to drive around again I think it
took us about three and a half minutes
four minutes
we allowed ourselves 15 minutes but now
we'd lost four minutes
so by this time all our adrenaline was
flowing
when you're doing something like that
what's running through your mind like
because what would have been the risk of
being caught I think I've you know don't
get me wrong you know the decisions that
we make are not taken lightly you know
we always we always knew the
consequences were either a lifetime in
prison or a deaf sentence
um
because as Robert if you only get one
opportunity to go right because you know
the flying's the flying Squad have had
to shoot the kill policy for a number of
years so our biggest fear of going in on
any job is not the fact that we're doing
it it's the fact that when we come out
they're going to shoot us in a chest so
that that's that's a that's a big thing
all right rang the bell in the the main
security came down
we said we've had a report to someone on
the roof we're a fast response robbery
Squad and we need to get access to the
building
there's a little bit of hesitation and I
said open the door when we need to get
in and the next thing they Buzz the buzz
Us in they buses through the
thermostatic pressure room and then they
put us into the foyer so so we we got
through the first the first part of it
and then we was in the foyer the night
to explain to them uh what was going on
about someone on the roof
uh and then like buses through the next
turn Styles and then the CCT Suite this
was our biggest problem because they all
had panny buttons so what I did I took
the head of security aside and said
listen have any of your guys been up on
the roof and they said no none of us
have I said what he said why he said uh
I said because we've had information
that a person is climbing up one sort of
roof was dressed as a security guard
so I said for my protection and my
officer protection I'm going to Cuff
everybody in here and that includes all
your CTS camera guys so I said stand up
and they all stood up when we cuffed
them I took them out into the
into the stairwell and uh
brought the dog through and we looked on
the CCT cameras and we could see where
all the other security guys were
um so we we uh we just asked them to
come down we got one of the guys that
called them all one down at a time and
as they came at the left or down the
stairs we just cuffed them and then put
them in a stairwell
we don't we then round up a few
technicians and then um a few cleaners
and we cuffed them up and then we left
them with a dog handler and we just
reassured them that you know look
everything's going to be fine but we
need to make a sweeper of the whole
whole uh building we then went to the
the Mainframe computer room which was a
floor down below which which had all the
circuit breakers for all the cameras on
the on the level upstairs and we took
that out I got on reception pulled it
and in two seconds later the phone went
off it was a private security company
and I said listen what's going on all
our cameras have gone down what's the
problem and we just said look we've had
uh we've had a surge in the Mainframe
computer system
um I take guys running now should be up
and running between you know 30 and 45
minutes uh give something back then and
we'll update you and he went boom
for me that was the only part of the job
that we couldn't we couldn't plan for
because
we don't know whether we needed a code
to give them a coded number or a coded
message
um but thank God uh you know just just
so fast enough to uh those just uh we
gave him an explanation and he and he
took it and uh he went about his uh his
job
I then I didn't radio for the for the
guys to come across the technicians and
the Specialists and then my other pal
took them upstairs to the room
they proceeded to to download and take
out all the motherboards
about 20 minutes into the job
um a car pulled up
and we thought it may have been like um
the old Bill there was two technicians
they came to the door we buzzed them in
uh and I just said to my guy in
reception just let him go through and if
they come to our floor we cuff them up
if not we'll just let them go and do
what I gotta do
um and then and another before I knew
they come up and listen it went past my
floor and uh they went about the
business I told my guy in a recession to
keep keep an eye on him and he did that
I never told all my guys that were there
I was wanting them to keep moving I
don't want to stop
as I'm looking on the camera is all I
can see was was two bags coming out of
time because we have built Big laundry
bags so laundry bags are coming out to a
time so I could have some idea of how
crooked they were going and every now
and I say that we need to move it a
little bit quicker uh because we we've
now got about 35 minutes
um
and and the next thing I know is two two
two and uh you know you know I could I
could I could feel the anxiety and
tension you know building up you know
because we were we were narrowing now
for like you know 15 minutes but we said
another 10 minutes to spare
we had to get a certain number of uh of
motherboards I mean it was 120 of them
we needed all them
because the information that we were
taking was also part of that we wanted
to get rid of everything so they
couldn't they couldn't access it and and
find out what we'd taken and about two
about three minutes to ten I called it
we came and everyone came down with two
bags we all took two bags each
we left the older security guards and
everybody cuffed on the stairs and we
told them we'd be back in a minute first
of all the tech guys went out put their
bags in uh and the specialist went
across the road and he disappeared he'd
already took his laptop in the bits and
pieces that he had and he was on his on
his way
um we then took all that stuff and and
put it on the van
and then uh we pulled away and uh
we we drove up Rock College Street and
as we came level with uh kenishtown
police station
uh Noel broglos with all police cars
come across us at six or seven old build
Vans
um thank God for us you know I can
always remember mate in the back again
screaming what the going on you
know in the dark I did a dog barking and
everything else and I said just just
calm down and it's just you know it's
just a normal reaction it was now six
minutes past ten and apparently the old
build had gained entry to it and they'd
surrounded the whole building but we was
we was level at Holmes Road and all of a
sudden they pulled past us and I just
looked at my pound was just like a
little grin and we cracked it we're
going to get through this and as we
drove out to the to the Kennestone
station uh train station there's another
entrance and next thing is there's about
10 to 15 police cars come fly now and I
remember through the old Bill walking
past and and I looked over and they and
I went and they went right to us and
then we just drove on you know so we
drove we drove up kenishtown we then
drove up to the slaughter I'm not gonna
say where it was uh because I never ever
found it
um we drove about 40 minutes and we went
and parked it all ago in a slower we
then gave the cars and everything that
someone to get rid of we went back and
changed all our gear and got rid of it
and then we went out we met uh and a
little celebration drink
I was tasked in with uh with my other
pal to take all the motherboards down to
Kenwood ass over in Hampstead
um where we met the fixer
and we pulled into the into the car park
there and my pal stay with that and put
the Keyser in um
on the back wheel
and he he went across to a bench and
just sat there looking at it
and I went down to the little cafe and
uh a little calf restaurant and when I
got there he said
okay now what have you guys done he said
I've been listening to it on on the news
and on the papers he said the Ocean's 11
style Heist he said what made you guys
old bill
I said it just seemed that the most the
easiest way of getting in there that
cause any any dramas and I said have you
have you have you sorted out of money
because he transferred all that money
into different accounts
and he said yes we checked online uh for
another part of mine said everything's
dropped and I give I said like okay the
van's like the road with the keys are in
a on the back wheel and he then sent his
guy up there he then took um took the
van away
and
I just got up on Waterway and that was
the end of
and so once you successfully pulled off
that job were you afraid of being caught
no no
you know is it you know I've been in
this game for years and I
you know
if you get away with 50 jobs and you get
called for one you know that's going
some you know most people don't get
caught for the first jobs you know
because this this was
um
this involves some of the leading banks
in in America at JP Morgan and some
leading Banks
um we realized very very quickly
um the powers that beer will shyness
shutting this job down because
uh the Nick that evening and the next
day we had we had in the evening
standard was Oceans 11 star hire some
men dressed as a
um
as police officers with dogs and
everything girls that was all there and
the next day there was nothing
you know then it then it became a
burglary
and then and then and then they put a
statement outside in a very little that
we sold five million pounds off of
motherboards and Pentium chips but no
data they said they forensically uh
checked everything but nothing was taken
so we thought brilliant uh but and then
they said there was only three of us
and then all of a sudden it just went
off off the radar but we don't know you
know you know we don't realize at a time
that they put a 70-man squad on us I can
remember a couple of months later I was
um I was in my girlfriend's flat
and um
I I normally get R4 five o'clock every
morning this is a habit of mine
and uh
I I was ready and as I looked over over
the balcony I saw a woman walk past than
in a guy
and I thought it just doesn't look right
you know
um so you know I just I walked through I
picked up my rucksack about 30 Grand in
it uh I jumped up onto the onto the roof
and I ran along in about three or four
hundred yards where she lived in these
flats and and I went down a ladder and I
jumped about 10 or 15 foot and as I came
out all I saw was was all the old Bill
going in about 25 ended all going into
her flat
she was up like two floors three floors
um and that was it and then after that I
was on a run for for a year
but I went and rented that canal boat
and in fact I actually for the first
three months I actually parked my canal
boat behind Verizon
because at the Canada and I thought this
would probably be the last place that
ever going to look for me so I stayed
there for three months and then I moved
up to Northampton
and then and then I ran out a little
cottage in Lee grave
and after about a year because I was
coming down and seeing my family and my
kids and all that and I thought you know
what I'm
I'm gonna get a Dodge and I'm gonna go
over to Thailand on my other little guy
fighter
so I I sorted out a passport and um
that evening I'd arranged to go to to
Thailand I got the ticket bought for me
and everything else
and I can remember coming out of my
little Gaff and walking out the road uh
just to go and get go to the shop get
signed away
and next thing the whole street came
alive of old bill
and the next thing I know the cars came
across the the grass heading towards me
as I looked round one one was heading
behind me then A van pulled up and then
the next thing I knew I was on the floor
and uh
and then it was over you know it was
quite a relief really
unfortunately
um MI5 or MI6 since they've they've come
back to England they've made a concerted
effort towards criminals now to take us
down and they got a photo recognition
everywhere now and apparently I was seen
in West Hampstead on a facial
recognition and they then mapped me back
to to Lee grave and that's where they
were they applied up the area and when
they saw me
they pounced on me and I took the the
first opportunity to take me down which
is
which is what they do
and what were you sentenced with
I got sentences 17 years
um which I've always a little bit harsh
at the time because um
we never use any guns
I've done I've done a I've done eight
years four and a half months of that
sentence
um for me at this time you know I've
been in prison and been in care for most
of my life as a young kid and I've done
a four-year sentence as a young man as
well and and with that I I sent they
sent me they put me in the patches and
they sent me to pennantville and and
when I when I was there because I had a
couple of busted ribs in the shoulder
uh they they sent a psychologist to see
me
and um
and up until that time I never actually
spoken about
my life for being in care because I
always normalized it
um
and
after six or seven weeks of talking to
so it's like a forensic psychologist
um I decided that there was an
experimental prison called Grandin
Underwood
um
is a therapeutic prison it holds 228 men
it was supposed to be the most dangerous
in society the serial killers child
Killers wife Killers pedophile's rapist
everything now
and these are these are the people I was
with that killed kids
they killed families and that but
I learned a lot a lot about tolerance
then a lot of our understanding
a lot about Shame about guilt about
embarrassment
and over that two and a half period uh
turn off your period I I sort of really
got in touch with who I was
um it made me see that going to Care
really was a
was something I really normalized but it
wasn't normal I think
as a 10 11 year old kid uh being beaten
by a grown men
wasn't really conducive to turn him into
a productive member of society
they're not going to blame I'm not going
to blame
me being beaten I'm not going to blame
me being in Cal I'm not going to blame
social economic factors in my life
because the decisions that I made were
mine you know there are lots of kids
that I met in care
that had been being the same way and
then went on to lead productive lives
um I'd be stupid to say that
I don't regret it
um
I think it made me who I am
unfortunately I still get looked at from
now from time to time because um
no motherboards were ever recovered
no money was ever recovered
and only two of us have ever been nicked
um at the ten of us so
so I know that no one gross us up
and there was no one in a firm that
would have done that otherwise we'd have
all been nicked and I'm not going to
defend what I did you know there's
always victims in this I'm not going to
say that the the
Banks still millions of of people and
that justifies me doing it it was just a
job and my job was crime
I had to strip down to next to nothing
and grease out put a towel over to cut
section of bar off the window so it
wouldn't scratch my back and labored
myself out while still wrenched that up
just another little inch probably
strangling everybody had always hated
since childhood but just enough for me
to get out